meu nome é juliana a a crise eu vou
falar um pouco dela não está aqui comigo
mas é quem faz comigo projeto é bom o
que eu vou falar aqui hoje assim é faz
algum tempo que eu tenho o privilégio de
contar histórias de buscas profissionais
de algumas pessoas que eu nunca nem vi
na vida né
através desse projeto que chama continue
curioso eu sempre fui meio fascinado
assim por essa história de trabalho como
trabalhe o trabalho nos definir é uma
boa continuidade do que andré estava
falando aqui
claro que eu percebi que eu sou
fascinado agora um pouco mais velho mas
eu sempre aprendo aquela pergunta quando
alguém faz um pouquinho você né conta
essa história ea gente sempre começa
falando assim eu sou juliana eu sou
publicitária ou a eu sou pedro seu
professor o são joão o engenheiro né
é é é fato sempre a segunda coisa que
você falou sobre você sua profissão
então como é que é isso tem um grande
peso na nossa vida sempre girou é uma
fascinação né
e por isso que o projeto nasceu e hoje
eu vim falar pra vocês aqui não são
verdades absolutas e nem a filosofias né
o que eu queria contar é o projeto
através das histórias que a gente
recebeu e não sejam versão história
super profundas assim e pessoas que
abriram os seus corações e que
fascinaram a gente né então começar com
falando como tudo começou
tudo começou exatamente com esse meio
aqui
enviei para cris no dia 6 de março de
2012 é e no e-mail me apresento né a
gente tinha se visto umas duas vezes na
vida só eu me apresento e convidou ela
para participar do projeto esses vocês
lerem e se reparar que eu falo que é um
projeto bem cru que não está estruturado
que o projeto tem dado se inverte o
cliente né
louca claro que eu vou fazer isso né e
massacres
pelo contrário ela falou pirado vamos
fazer isso agora e janeiro
13 o site entrou no ar com essa
descrição que eu falei pra vocês
continuo curioso é mau é web série
documental sobre buscas e
questionamentos
conversamos com pessoas que se
desprenderam de um jeito convencional de
levar a vida para caminhar em direção ao
desconhecido sem saber muito bem porquê
entendemos que quando é o próprio
destino que está em jogo e ninguém entra
para perder
a ofensa das coisas aqui descobertas são
feitas no trabalho nas pessoas próximas
e principalmente em si mesmo
não sabemos qual o jeito é melhor ou se
existe um jeito certo
durante o caminho para já a resposta do
que a gente encontrou foram perguntas
não importa quais foram é o que importa
é que a gente ainda sair pronta toda vez
que eu ler esse texto é eu fico pensando
que uma o que eu acho mais difícil a
criação de um texto é fazer com que ele
reflita uma verdade né sentir ao ou
aumentar ou é distorcer o fato é fazer
com que ele seja genuíno e ao longo do
tempo fui percebendo que esteja não
refletia só a minha verdade ele refletia
verdade de muita gente né
muitas pessoas ea primeira delas na
primeira pessoa que a gente encontra
pelo caminho foi a maria pedroso a
marília foi personagem do nosso primeiro
episódio da websérie né
então a gente seguiu a marília no dias
de trabalho e um papa durante a
entrevista para fazer o episódio
a gente tem que entender por que ela
resolveu trocar um trabalho em um
escritório do trabalho de fotógrafa
freelancer e numa das falas e lembro que
ela dizia bom eu acordava às sete da
manhã eu saí de casa às sete da manhã e
voltava para casa às nove da noite e eu
não tinha tempo pra nada e eu acho que
isso é uma sensação de desperdício em
dois dias
a divulgação deste vídeo saiu do nosso
controle assim tudo que o que começou
naquele meio virou um negócio gigantes
em que a gente não esperava realmente
nosso controle
vários meios de comunicação nos
procuraram querendo respostas cliente
saber mais sobre o projeto e aí a partir
disso histórias bem parecidas com a da
manilha de pessoas que identificaram
começar a chegar de vários
lugares a gente recebe as áreas do rio
de são paulo e do rio grande do sul
o andré paraná do ceará de portugal e da
argentina da espanha
foram milhares de histórias da história
a gente reparou que essas histórias é
era muito mais uma vontade das pessoas
abrirem seus corações né então é são
textos aqui que eu tirei algumas delas
como estar incomodando mas eu preciso
conversar com alguém eu nem sei para
quem estou escrevendo e nem sente se vai
parar mas porque acho que vocês é lindo
e me deu vontade de compartilhar uma
história e aí procurando achar um elo
entre todas essas histórias que a gente
perceber que muitas delas se não todas
começaram porque as pessoas resolveram a
perguntar é se perguntar a se questionar
se é pra fazer isso o que eu vou fazer o
que me motiva o que eu tô fazendo a
minha vida o meu papel e o que eu
preciso fazer para estar satisfeito com
as respostas
nenhuma dessas histórias estava cheio de
respostas é pelo contrário muitas
estavam cheias de perguntas e aí é uma
coisa engraçada porque é o sujo
perguntando para uma lavada porque eu
também não vou saber responder nem eu
também porque meu trabalho no escritório
por uma vida não convencional de
finanças
em nenhuma delas também é legal falar
estava cheia de finais felizes né
a gente sabe que a gente gostaria de
pensar que é sair da escola fez
faculdade me encontrei estou trabalhando
estou feliz não é assim que a felicidade
funciona infelizmente é são histórias
longas e assim em texto superdensa de
umas intimidades que a gente jamais
imaginou que teria com pessoas que a
gente nunca nem viu na vida ea proposta
agora que eu quero dividir algumas
dessas histórias com vocês
eu tenho um filho de três meses e mora
com a mulher está em risco de perder o
único emprego que tenho e com o passar
do tempo e pressão da situação estou
aquecendo e perdi o amor próprio
estou querendo sair mas não posso você
sair não quero mais nada parecido
estou virando por não ser algo que gosta
e por parte dos meus pais é normal é
preciso viver de forma infeliz pra ter
apenas dinheiro
é interessante que histórias como esta
noite recebe esses são exemplos a gente
recebe muitas histórias como essa nos
mostram como a escolha de uma profissão
vai muito além das nossas próprias
escolhas nem as expectativas de
terceiros contam muito né às vezes até
demais
levava uma vida banal sempre tentando
encaixar quanto às exigências sociais um
vazio que nunca era preenchido me levou
a uma depressão grave
foram 9 com tentativas de suicídio
com a ajuda de medicações saindo daquele
estado depressivo devagar distante de
tudo encontra sem querer a vida de novo
comecei a observar as coisas o mundo de
uma mediadora nesse caso era uma câmera
e mediador entre eu eo mundo só queria
deixar registrado o meu amor que eu
tenho pela fotografia é pra mim com
histórias como essa fica claro que o
problema não está em trabalhar mas sim
perder a sua essência do trabalho a
gente parar para reparar realmente olhar
no olho da outra pessoa a gente vai ver
que dores silenciosa estão por aí o
tempo todo a gente às vezes só escolhe
não vê o interessante a gente quando a
gente resolve realmente abrir nossos
olhos
hoje estou terminando o curso técnico do
senai e voltei a ser estagiária deu o
primeiro passo na nova carreira
estou trabalhando em uma oficina
mecânica comprei uma vez que todo
estou mais feliz do que nunca aprendem
alguma causa todos os dias é essa moça -
disse que junto com uma carreira está aí
fosse um casamento de seis anos né
e essa é a nossa impressão dela com um
novo amor que ela encontrou a gente faz
é para sempre algumas interpretações em
desenho das histórias é que as pessoas
nos mandam e essa foi uma delas
é bom a imaginei que hoje aqui é uma
pessoas chaves enfim donos empresários
que têm como função orientar pessoas né
então as próximas histórias realmente
foram escolhidas para vocês
que para mostrar o seu poder de
realmente ganhar ou perder um talento
me dei conta que todos os meus gostos
não era o momento que eu estava
trabalhando essa era a melhor parte
o meu desgosto era com a forma que a
advocacia presente se apresentava e o
que exigiu de mim
roupas caras carros para desfilar a
postura oficial com vários pedantes isso
era o sistema isso era o que eu via
todos os dias no escritório assim uma
sociedade inversão micro atmosfera está
impregnado dos valores da corporação e
todos vivem suas vidas absolutamente
voltados para simon
é interessante o que eu acho
interessante nessa história que ela
representa que ninguém sobrevive sem
mudanças né
nem as pessoas e também nem as empresas
em nome de 2000 fez prova para o
mestrado 2011 fez prova para o mestrado
quando soube da aprovação comuniquei ao
meu chefe que pediria a demissão já que
seria muito difícil me manter na empresa
durante o período das aulas
eles disseram que me liberariam que não
precisaria pedir demissão
pois então com chegou em abril de 2012
me comunicar por causa dos estudos
eu teria que ser mandado embora estava
sem bolsa de mestrado porque trabalhava
ainda ficaria sem meu salário é como é
importante é que as empresas percebam
que o real valor delas são pessoas e não
só percebeu mais como que haja tal forma
que pessoas simplesmente sejam tratadas
com pessoas e não máquinas se confessar
que eu faço hoje não me deixe feliz
também interessante possibilidade de
crescimento de carreira
jeff que gosta de mim salário bom enfim
tudo como dizem de mão beijada
interessante a cara das pessoas quando
você fala que isso não te faz feliz
começou aí uma aventura interessante
hoje estou trabalhando meio período
segunda terça e quarta vez k social
coloca o computador na bolsa e vou ser
executiva
quinta sexta sábado e domingo passa por
dias de auto-descoberta essa pra mim é
uma história que exemplifica muito
aquela frase mágica que é precisamos
conversar é tão sim
mas às vezes é tão difícil de dizer
antes de ir pra aquela moça bonita eu
vou apresentar a gente tentou entender
mais sobre essas questões né
durante o projeto não só lendo as
histórias fazendo episódio sempre busca
entender mais sobre isso e aí em são
paulo a gente resolveu fazer um vídeo e
compartilhar com vocês aqui hoje
especialmente é e neste vídeo a gente
fez só duas perguntas para desconhecidos
na rua eo resultado foi esse aqui
[Música]
tem tem tem várias coisas que eu não
gosto do trabalho você me perdoe o que
eu não goste quer que eu responda a
mesma talvez o tema mais tensa seja
realmente relação com pessoas é dico
primeiro lugar assim é a dificuldade de
obtenção de informação ea falta de
comunicação entre áreas
então cada setor tem um chefe e subchefe
tem gerente não sei que cada todos têm
que estar com o mesmo o mesmo foco é
construir se procura conversar não vamos
entender aqui né conversar comunicação
melhor coisa que tem
eu acho que sempre há pontos a melhorar
a sua flexibilidade do horário para se
sair um almoço para entrar às vezes tem
algumas coisas que fazem resolver
seria melhor não tem aquela coisa fixa
entre as 8 65 e se abrir mão um pouco da
sua vida pessoal para o trabalho em
avatar mas não gosta
enfim eu acho que o sistema todo no
geral tá errado
[Música]
sei a razão da nossa mínima idéia é
mudar lá no meu trabalho
olha se essa fosse a chef mesmo num
mundo ideal acho que consiga mais aberta
mais transparente conversando acho que a
melhor solução que tem cinco porque o
cara tem só quem disse que a conversa
não adianta um cuidado acaba se ligando
mas nunca tive um caso extremo de
problema eu jogo sempre umas vezes se eu
tivesse possibilidade de mandar pessoas
embora a gente tenta não se fala mas não
adianta mudar a situação
rocha também nosso próprio não eu
gostaria até de um trabalho sem que
pudesse fazer comigo ao vice mas tem que
ter esse preparo tanto do lado da pessoa
que quer trabalhar em casa quanto da
empresa conseguir ter confiança não
funcionar de que o cara não vai ficar
desperdiçando
o que eu penso muito engessados na
verdade não tem uma participação que
somará vão decidir como melhor trabalhar
numa cooperativa é uma empresa que
presta serviço e tem que cumprir as
normas pré estabelecidas pela empresa
pelo o grupo no caso das vezes entre as
empresas têm o costume de deixar
enterrado também alguns talentos das
pessoas
mas aí cabe a cada um desenvolver e
mostrar que está ali para fazer a coisa
acontecer na super feliz lá e ver não
tem nada hoje que eu falar eu não gosto
disso para trabalhar com ele porque eu
amo senão não ia trabalhar ficar em casa
porque senão esses pequenos problemas
que acontecem sim no dia a dia vão
tornar sua vida um inferno
o gostoso é bom né
tudo que os trabalhos se você gostar
gente essa experiência
[Música]
um ano depois de fazer ver esse vídeo eu
cheguei a uma conclusão pouco óbvia mas
que talvez tivesse guardado em alguma
gaveta mental assim cheia de pó à
conclusão que o problema os problemas
com um trabalho tão tão bem longe de ser
um problema causado pelo trabalho
problema não está no que você exerce
problema ta como você se sente quando
você exerce né
então como o senhor brilhantemente do
vídeo disse
o trabalho se você gostar é bom eu penso
que o trabalho deveria ser um
facilitador é algo que ajude a você se
encontrar e não a se perder é loucura
pensar que existe separação entre vida
profissional e vida pessoal é loucura
pensar quem falou isso um dia é loucura
não existisse no âmbito profissional é
também a sua vida pessoal
é dentro de todas as histórias que a
gente recebeu e me surpreendi com a
frase de um garoto que o menino de 20
anos que a resistência que ele decidiu
empreender ao invés de seguir por um
caminho de estágios né
e ele disse um conselho que recebi uma
vez e mudou a minha forma de ver as
coisas foi olha para o mundo à sua volta
e pensa que tudo que você admira não foi
criado por pessoas melhores do que você
ou com algum dom diferente
elas apenas seguiram em frente eu penso
que o fim do trabalho como é hoje ele
existe né a gente sempre vai falar de
trabalho mas não vai ser mais trabalho
vai acontecer sem nenhuma mudança de
nome eu penso a gente não pode carregar
mais sentimento e coração quando a gente
fala de trabalho já que é uma parcela
tão grande da nossa vida
a finalizar eu queria deixar uma
reflexão aqui em forma de pergunta pra
vocês a mesma pergunta que eu fiz pra
todos essas pessoas que já participaram
da nossa web série
a pergunta é será que a gente consegue
carregar mais verdade nos nossos gestos
mais cotidianos como as nossas relações
com as pessoas
os amigos e com o nosso trabalho é a
gente acredita que se questionar é o
único começo mil melhores dotes e as
respostas vão vir se vocês continuarem
perguntando obrigado
[Aplausos]